[Music]
hey wisecrack
jared here today we're talking about the
movie that made batman v superman look
like
an art house masterpiece justice league
god i wish it was that one okay
technically super friends but still
better than justice league
yeah that's the one so full disclosure
justice league is
not good it's trite af i believe in
truth
but i'm also a big fan of justice and
yeah if that line didn't tip you off
they also totally botched superman
worst of all the film neutered all the
thematic ambitions of its predecessor
throwing the superman as christ metaphor
into the trash
but beneath all these flaws there's one
central issue that makes justice league
so forgettable after subjecting
ourselves to all 121 minutes of this
film
over and over again seriously i think
i've seen it like five times
we think the film's main failure comes
from its inability to juggle two things
advancing the main conflict with
steppenwolf and introducing us to our
new palette of characters
while in a better film these two aspects
would work in concert with each other
in justice league it's the complete
opposite
every time we have backstory or
character development it seems to come
at the expense of the main story
to understand how this is even possible
though we first need to understand one
fundamental lesson in screenwriting
dramatic action welcome to this
wisecrack edition on the justice league
what went wrong and
yeah if you can spoil a turd spoilers
for justice league ahead
also batman v superman and infinity war
but first
a quick recap justice league takes place
in a world without
superman after the man of steel was
killed by doomsday bruce wayne is racked
by
guilt well supposedly but bruce doesn't
have much time to dwell on this because
a new world ending threat is knocking on
earth's door
in the form of steppenwolf the end of
worlds
he lived only to conquer steppenwolf
wants to turn
earth into a hellscape but to do so
he'll need to reclaim
the mother boxes essentially dc's
version of the infinity stones which
were reactivated by superman's death
these boxes have been guarded by the
ancient tribes of amazons atlanteans and
men for centuries
but now that steppenwolf is back batman
has to rally the old alliance and build
a crack
team to stop him you got familiar
favorites like bruce wayne and diana
prince
along with a sheldon cooper inspired
flash a dothraki aquaman and a cgi
cyborg
so what is dramatic action while the
term applies to all dramatic writing
playwright david edgar summed it up best
in his book how plays work
by defining it as a project followed by
a contradiction
now i know that sounds like a russian
nesting doll of terms so
let's break it down by a project edgar
means more or less a
goal usually stated with a subject verb
and object
so for example when batman tries to
bribe an icelandic village into helping
him find aquaman
i'll give you 25 000 to talk to this man
right now we could state the project as
batman looks for aquaman subject verb
object
pretty simple right but batman and
aquaman can't be besties right off the
bat
otherwise there'd be no conflict and
that rotten tomatoes score would slide
even further that's where edgar's idea
of the contradiction comes in
typically our heroes don't get what they
want in a scene
they run into the contradiction or more
simply
obstacles as it turns out for bruce
aquaman doesn't want to play nice with
friends
the fight comes we'll need you don't
count on a batman
why not because i like you coming here
digging into my business getting into my
life
to edgar the best way to express the
contradiction is a basic
but statement so if we were to put the
project and contradiction together for
this scene
we get something like this batman looks
for aquaman
but aquaman is a dick now the reason why
dramatic action is such a big deal
is that it advances conflict characters
make certain choices in the pursuit of
their goals
only for new obstacles to pop up in
response to these choices
because the contradiction always gets in
the way of the project
no scene should end on the same note it
began
just look at batman who after being
scorned by aquaman wonders if he lost
him forever
so you say you have no way of
reconnecting with this
aquaman oh i put a tracking device in
his coat
he left without it this is what
screenwriting guru robert mckee means
when he says that a scene
must turn in his book story mckee writes
if the value-charged condition of the
character's life stays
unchanged from one end of a scene to the
other
nothing meaningful happens the scene has
activity
talking about this doing that but
nothing changes in value
it is a non-event it's that last point
that's relevant
without dramatic action conflict won't
advance
and the scene won't turn and this is
where justice league
seriously screws up while most of the
scenes do have dramatic action
and do turn they do so by focusing on
our heroes individual arcs at the
expense of the conflict
and even though scenes turn it's done in
a way that's hasty and ungratifying
let's look at aquaman again following
the mother box being stolen from
atlantis we see him
shrug it off the project of this scene
would be aquaman wants to abandon
atlantis
and that makes sense based on the
character we saw earlier
a man whose only allegiance is to
himself strong man as strong as alone
you ever heard that that's not a saying
that's the opposite of what the saying
is but then comes the contradiction and
tell me if you see a problem here your
mother left you to save your life
cannot imagine how it hurt her what it
cost her
but you're not a defenseless child now
it would have been her responsibility to
follow that monster to the surface and
stop it
now it's yours
yeah so that character we have no idea
who she is and
that backstory yeah never hinted at so
while sure there is a contradiction we
could express it as
but some rando convinces aquaman to stay
it feels cheap like a purely artificial
and convenient plot device
almost as cheap as another poor dceu
turn
martha a deus ex martha if you will
as it turns out this isn't the only time
justice league seems to cheat when it
comes to dramatic action in our
character scenes
you smell good to prove our point let's
look at one of the most frustrating
moments in the movie
the discussion to bring superman back to
life while we could talk about how the
project of this scene
bruce argues to bring back superman
defies the logic of its predecessor
he has the power to wipe out the entire
human race and if we believe
there's even a one percent chance that
he is our enemy we have to take it as an
absolute certainty by concocting some
weird pet cemetery debate
we mean bring him back in like a yay
he's back way not in like a
like a pet cemetery scenario
it's actually the contradiction that
really gets us while bruce advocates for
superman's revival he encounters his
first obstacle in the form of diana
who's worried about
what happens if the plan fails you're
risking lives
theirs and maybe countless more we don't
have time for a control group
is it a risk yes but it's necessary why
because of your guilt
now if this had you scratching your head
you're not alone because
nowhere in the preceding hour did the
film show a bruce wayne tormented by
guilt
no flashbacks no dreams no coping
mechanisms
and if you think we're being unduly
harsh then know that all of these were
employed in batman v superman to explain
bruce's extreme distrust for the man of
steel
just like with aquaman the scene has
dramatic action
and yes it turns but only through
artificially inserted conflict
unsurprisingly there are some pretty big
consequences for making
so much of the dramatic action focus on
our heroes
very thin personal and interpersonal
arcs
in fact the film is so preoccupied with
rushing to set up our characters and
their own foibles
like flash's social awkwardness
aquaman's lone cop persona
cyborg self-hatred and diana's isolation
from the world
that it seemingly forgets steppenwolf
altogether
case in point consider the mother boxes
you know these
carried from planet to planet the mother
boxes combine to form the unity
an apocalyptic power that not only
destroys worlds
but transforms them into the primordial
hellscape of steppenwolf's birth world
well it might surprise you to learn that
batman arguably the protagonist of the
film
only learns of the box's importance at
the 30 minute mark
but surely the rest of the film and our
heroes are focused on keeping the boxes
from steppenwolf's poorly cgi'd hands
right yeah no the first box is stolen
from the amazons without any of our
heroes present
the second one features a measly
30-second fight scene with aquaman
and just to rub it in how little our
heroes care about the actual plot
the third and final motherbox is
basically stolen off screen while our
team is recovering from a superman
beatdown
the motherbox he has the last one
now i know what you guys are thinking
jared by assembling the team the justice
league
is stopping steppenwolf and while
there's definitely some merit to that
idea
this shouldn't be an either or scenario
to prove my point let's look at another
film with a very similar premise
infinity war in the film thanos is
hell-bent on destroying half of all life
by gathering the infinity stones after
bruce banner escapes thanos grasp in the
opening scene
the hulk enlists the help of doctor
strange and tony stark
if he gets his hands on all six stones
tony
he could destroy life on a scale
hitherto on dreamtop
importantly you'll notice three things
in this scene one
our heroes get together and learn of the
initial threat in under 15 minutes
two our heroes specifically strange and
vision
possess infinity stones that puts them
on a crash course with the plot
and most importantly three our hero's
personal problems are intermixed with
the conversation to stop
thanos who just saved your man's class
me i seriously don't know how you fit
your head into that helmet admit it you
should have ducked out when i told you
to if it wasn't already obvious stark
and strange aren't
exactly fond of each other and the
dramatic action of any given scene
is as much about stopping thanos as it
is about learning to work together
but as the two continue to fight
alongside each other their dysfunction
goes from tony reluctantly rescuing
strange
i gotta tell you he's not really my
friend saving his life is more of a
professional courtesy
too strange bartering the time stone
away to save tony's life
spare his life and i will give you the
stone
in this last instance the dramatic
action of the scene is equally about
plot
stopping thanos and character tony and
strange's relationship
the project is thanos wants to kill tony
and the contradiction is
but strange stops him by giving away the
time stone
and to be honest this moment resonated
now we'd be wrong to say that this kind
of interplay between our hero's personal
conflict and the actual plot is
absent in justice league but we'd also
be wrong to say that it's similar in
terms of quality or scale
let's look at the flash for example
while the film makes a point of showing
his desperate need for friends
i need friends this conflict doesn't
really manifest itself anywhere else in
the film
let alone in a confrontation with
steppenwolf the closest we have to it is
this
it's really cool you guys seem ready to
do battle and stuff but
full transparency i've never done battle
yes the dramatic action of the sequence
could be stated as
flash is scared to enter the fray
against steppenwolf but
batman convinces him but we have to ask
at
what part of the movie did flash
indicate to us that he had combat stage
fright
ultimately this scene feels like a
tenuous tie-in between barry's personal
struggles and stopping the world-ending
threat
and the film treats it as such after the
flash rescues the hostages the film
conveniently forgets any of his stage
fright yes it was gross
as a result these scenes often fail to
evoke the hallmark of good writing
aristotle's idea of catharsis or the
purification or projection of emotions
primarily through art because justice
league fails to properly tether our
character's personal journeys to the
action of the plot
we don't feel the proper emotions
anxiety fear
relief triumph none of it washes over us
sure we see diana and cyborg finally
coming out of hiding
we hear aquaman talk about friendship or
regrets
or something i don't want to die i'm
young there's [ __ ] that i want to do
i just feel like i've never really
embraced the sea or the land
i've been alone in my whole life but
because these aren't developed
and tied to the action of the plot
there's no catharsis
we as the audience just can't muster up
the energy to care
and we really can't emphasize this
enough this is exactly what infinity war
excels at consider the relationship
between tony stark and peter parker
which is developed
hand in hand with the main plot more
often than not our duo finds themselves
bickering like father and son in the
face of enemies
after all tony wants peter safe i know
what you're gonna say
you should not be here i was going to go
home i don't want to hear it it was such
a long way down and i just thought about
shooting and now i got to hear you're
stuck to the side of the ship and this
suit is ridiculously intuitive by the
way so
if anything it's kind of your fault that
i'm here what did you just say i take
that back
and this relationship affects the action
like when tony plays hardball for
peter's life when they're both mistaken
for thanos henchmen tell me where the
girl is or i swear to you i'm gonna
french fry this little freak let's do it
you shoot my guy and i'll blast him
let's go
more importantly because we see tony and
peter's dynamic grow
and change over the course of the film
we're invested in them
which makes moments like this
legitimately cathartic
in contrast all the resolution scenes of
the justice league characters feel
obligatory and
phoned in it's the difference between
feeling genuine emotion in the theater
and leaving saying well i i guess that
was a movie
in the end justice league stands as a
case study of a film
that fails to balance two very important
things
character and plot which i suppose makes
sense when you consider how they had to
establish
all these new franchises for movies to
come but what do you guys think
is dramatic action the best lens to
focus this problem
or are there bigger issues lurking in
the justice league